by our count more than four million
people on Florida's Atlantic coast are
under mandatory orders to evacuate the
reality as many of them will stay put
despite Dorian's threat that worries
emergency responders of course mark
Strassmann spoke to people in st.
Augustine Beach southeast of
jacksonville mark how are they preparing
for durian good morning st. Augustine
Beach has become ghost town Florida gas
stations convenience stores restaurants
they're all closed more people will
evacuate today more but not all probably
end up losing the shed but it's not the
house Chris Allen almost lost his house
three years ago
hurricane Matthew flooded his
neighborhood he says more than a foot of
water poured into his home we lost
everything we were out of our house for
over a year just about a year
financially it you know killed us
Alan's leaving for Jorian st. Augustine
Beach has a mandatory evacuation order
but other residents will ignore it do
you have a plan B or anything sergeant
Chris e Paget's checking on vulnerable
residents senior citizens like 76 year
old Holly Bo's and she's nervy enough to
stay put mandatory evacuation orders now
apply to roughly seven hundred thousand
coastal Floridians age 65 and up but no
state law lets Paget and force it
frustrating yes because they are in the
you know most dangerous and most likely
to flood or high winds and everything
like that
don't mention floods to Chris Allen it's
why he built this homemade dam before
leaving Matthew did not cut you a break
your hope Andorian does yes absolutely
back live now with the churning surf
here in san agustin beach with these
waves will probably get even bigger as
the day goes on here's what Chris Allen
told us about his experience with
Hurricane Matthew that is had it not
been for Matthew he probably would have
stayed put for durian what it also
taught him about a hurricane is this it
can get you Anthony
mark Strassmann thanks you can get
updates on hurricane durian on her
around the clock by using our CBS News
app you can also find our streaming
service CBS n at CBS news.com